so if you want to start playing the
guitar obviously the first thing you've
got to do
is get a guitar and i had said it on
very early in my mind that i wanted an
acoustic guitar not an electric guitar
i've played a couple of lectures before
but i've never owned one so i'm not
really going to talk about them
but when at the beginning i was trying
to uh work out which one i should buy i
really
knew nothing so these are just a few of
the things that i've picked up i'm going
to have a look at three different
guitars
now this is a nylon string guitar often
called a classical guitar
and these would be if you're not sure
whether you want to sort of long-term
invest in an instrument
these will be the cheapest kind of
guitars that are out there i'll explain
why later
now i what you'll get from a
nylon string guitar is as the name
suggests
um strings that are made out of nylon so
if you have a look
at a nylon string guitar these top three
strings one
two three they're called the top even
though physically on there on the bottom
because they're um they're tones the
pitch
is higher as opposed to these these
strings up up here
and these are the base strings so
they're lower they're deeper so that's
why
these are called the top strings here
anyway they're made out of nylon
so if you're um a beginner guitar
a guitarist rather you're probably not a
guitar if you're watching this
uh you'll probably find a nylon string
guitar the easiest to start on because
nylon as opposed to steel which i'll
show you in a second is much easier to
hold down for your fingers
at the beginning everyone's fingers
your fingertips on your non-writing hand
so the left hand is the one which holds
down the strings over here
everyone's fingers start out really soft
right but after a while holding down
these strings you can see that these top
ones are a nylon
and these ones over here are nylon but
they're coated in um
there they've had a metal wrapped around
them
after you hold these down for a while
your fingers will start to get calloused
and hard because
they've been holding down things so long
it's kind of the same reason why
the skin on the bottom of your feet is
calloused because you're always using
them to walk on things right
anyway you'll find this really easy to
um play or
comparatively easy to play and the kind
of sound that you get
is a quite soft sort of gentle sound so
it sounds like this right
so that's kind of a nice sound to start
off with the what i've found
over the years is that if you're playing
an island screen title and you're
playing with rhythm
because the um the notes are quite
gentle and soft together
they tend to blend together and they
have a less distinct sound like each
individual note so for instance if i
play a rhythm here like this
it's kind of harder to make out all of
the individual strings within that sound
they all kind of blur together so
that's one thing that i've noticed after
a while playing on string guitar and
comparing that to a steel string which
i'll show you in the moment
now what else do you want to know about
it what you'll find about an island
string guitar is it's also quite light
and it's easy to transport so you could
easily hold it with one hand
and feel quite comfortable with it but
um that's often where people begin
a nylon string guitar i think mainly
because they're cheap
okay now let's have a look at different
guitar
this guitar is um made by a brand of
manufacturer called uh samick that's
what the s is for it's part of the
greg bennett design series anyway this
is the guitar
that i first bought when i started
playing and
it's a steel string guitar also
sometimes called a folk
guitar and what you'll notice
immediately
is well these strings if you can look at
them closely
are made out of steel so when you hold
them down it presses against your
fingers
a lot more so when you're starting out
and your fingers haven't grown that much
strength
if you've been playing a nylon string
for a while and then you move over
to a um to a steel string what you often
find is you don't have the strength
to hold down the strings hard enough and
you'll get that buzz which everyone
hates so for instance if you play like
this
can you hear if i don't hold the strings
down hard enough
um you either don't get the sound of the
notes like that or when you hold them
down
see yeah yeah i i've developed a fair
bit of hamstrings
so it's it's hard to actually hold them
down not properly but anyway
um you'll hear that buzzing sound like
this
uh can i do it i'm holding down too hard
anyway it doesn't matter
so um you need more strength to play a
steel string guitar and in fact
if you play long enough if you have the
determination you can actually make your
fingers
bleed because the strings will cut
through your fingers particularly based
on
you know if you've got some really
really heavy strings
you can get different kinds of weighted
strings based on how loud you want to
play what kind of
style and that kind of thing now another
thing you'll notice
between the steel string and the nylon
string if i put them next to each other
is that the the neck
that's the that's the part here which
has the strings on it
the neck of the nylon string is actually
a fair bit wider than the neck of the
steel string
i don't really know why that is um but
that makes the um the nylon string
actually if
it helps to have bigger fingers when
you're holding it whereas the steel
string
all the strings are quite close together
now that's got its own challenges when
the strings are closer together
it's easy for one finger to get in the
way
of another string and accidentally hold
it down but that's just a minor thing to
know
now like i said before the nylon string
you get quite a soft
sound when you compare it to a steel
string most of the sounds are quite
hard and sharp in comparison so you get
these kinds of
sounds so i play the same sort of
so each of the notes rings out a lot
more distinctly which you pick up a lot
a lot clearer if you're playing rhythm
so if you're playing everything like
this
so you might find it easier to pick out
all of the um
the notes uh after a bit of experience
that are played on a steel string
a little more easily than on a um on the
marlin string
now a couple other things to note about
this guitar in particular
if you look up here as you go towards
the um the sound hole
you've got what's called a cutaway now
what's that about i used to think it's
just to make guitars look fancy
the main main reason why there's a
cutaway is because um depending on
what kinds of music you play if you play
a lot of uh
lead guitar which is you know um things
like this
uh when you've got when you've got
melodies in between lines so
if you're if you've got notes rather
than whole courtsui
so if you're playing that kind of thing
often the notes that are played for
those are much higher
than if you're playing just a rhythm
guitar so if you want to reach higher
notes you
can see that with the nylon string
there's a whole bunch of frets that you
literally can't reach
um up past here this is that's fret 12.
you're going to find it you're going to
find it anyone would find it difficult
to reach any of these frets up here
which kind of makes you wonder why do
they even put the frets there but that's
i don't know really why um i guess
there's a traditional number of frets
and they reach all the way up to the
sound hole
um so this guitar doesn't have a cutaway
so it's really kind of impractical to
reach up to here
so that's why some guitars will cut away
like that
and that will allow guitarists if you
want to play those really high notes
like up here
there's fret 12 there and so i can go
all the way up to 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 i can reach 20. i don't know why
you'd want to play for 20 but anyway you
can
um so that's what the cutaway is about a
couple of things
else about this guitar you might notice
is that um this guitar is quite a lot
thinner
if you have a look um you know what's
the distance that the
guitar is extending out of your body um
so what that'll produce is a bit less
sound the the bigger the volume of the
guitar the more
like as in the bigger the physical
volume like in cubic
centimeters the more sound it will
produce now the reason why this
particular guitar can get away with
being a bit thinner which
for some people makes it a bit more
comfortable to play is
this is what's called a semi-acoustic so
even though it is an acoustic guitar not
plugged in at the moment and i can make
sound
you also have what's called a pickup now
you can tell a guitar which has a pickup
because on the top of the guitar there
will be all of this like fancy
electronic stuff and i'll have a look at
that another time probably
but what that means is for this guitar
you've got underneath underneath the
bridge
you've got some some sensors which pick
up the vibrations of the strings
and then they can output that to a
speaker or an amplifier right
so you can see right down the bottom
here there's a hole
and for different guitars it's at
different places this is where you put
in
a lead or a cable which would plug into
a speaker and
you can play this out and um it's it's
super loud
so that's why this guitar can get away
with being a bit thinner and getting
less volume out
because often people play it you know
plugged in
so the actual sound of the guitar
produces is not that important
so like i said this is the guitar that i
started off playing uh
a nice sort of beginner's guitar it's
sort of what it cost uh 500
one last thing which is handy and
unusual quite rare i've hardly ever seen
another guitar like this but
you remember i pointed out all this
fancy electronic stuff before
one of the cool things that's included
in it is a tuner so the tuner
is built into the guitar but we'll talk
about tuners another time that's a big
topic
okay so the third and last guitar i'm
going to show you this morning
is this one here okay now this is a um
this is a maten guitar so again you can
see the um the brand tends to be up here
if you're looking for who makes a guitar
or also inside the sound hole you can
sometimes see there's some writing and
labeling and all that kind of thing
so how is this guitar different to um
the guitar that i just showed you
well similarities sorry first it's still
another steel string guitar
okay so the basic sound is still the
same
um differences are number one your the
most immediate notice
things that people notice is that
there's no cut away okay and the reason
for that is that
um usually we're playing reader guitar
at icf anyway
so we don't need to tend to use these
strings
and i'm sorry these frets i mean and
when you have a cutaway
because just like making the guitar
thinner you're losing internal volume
for the guitar
guitars with cutaways are just that
little bit softer
than guitars without them they also tend
to be more expensive because it's
difficult to actually
put that shape into the body of the
guitar
so this one doesn't have a cutaway you
also notice that it's
it is actually thicker so this is a full
thickness guitar but that's not because
it's only an acoustic guitar just like
the previous one the samick
this also has a slot where you can plug
in
a cable which will go to a speaker or an
amplifier
okay other things this is made out of
different materials
so the kind of wood you'll often see
subtle differences in the appearance
and also the sound of a guitar now
you'll probably get
better at picking up the differences
between guitars as you get more
experience
but i'll just play this for you and you
can hear the distance for yourself if it
comes through the mic anyway so
what did i play before i think i played
this
play a bit of rhythm for you let's see
i'll play it in let's play in c shall we
so minor differences okay so
one other thing you want to have a look
at which was on the previous guitar
and this guitar but not on the nylon
string this is what's called a pick
guard so as the name suggests it's
um to protect your peak or your plectrum
from damaging the the nice fancy wood on
your guitar so as you can see when i
play
like so
um you're not really meant to but just
naturally the the motion of your hand
will take the peak and it will actually
strike against
you the body of your guitar as it goes
through those final strings
it it makes an impact there so that's
just meant to protect the wood um
and some some of the pick guards are
really fancy that's just an m logo
anyway so there you go that's um three
different kinds of acoustic guitar
and um oh by the way this one this one
costs about uh let's see
um fourteen hundred dollars okay so
a bit of a difference in price again
that's mostly for um the the
difference in quality in the sound and
also also some of the things like the
electronics that are in it but
again that's a topic for another day i
hope that helps you to distinguish
between some of the
different kinds of acoustic guitar out
there a lot of things come down to
um just personal preference and taste
things that i was looking for in my
first guitar for instance
are things like say if you have a look
it's really hard to see even from
far far away let alone from your
distance
but the distance from the the strings
down to the fretboard that's often
called the action of the guitar
now the higher the action is or the
bigger the action
is the more volume you can get out of a
guitar but it also because you have to
hold those strings down
it also makes the guitar much harder to
play because you have to hold down
harder
so one of the things that i was looking
for in my my early guitar was
a low action an easy action if you like
that made the strings very
easy to to hold down because you know
it's no use getting a really good
sounding guitar
if it's so hard to play that you end up
never playing it and then you don't
learn it and it's that's a bit silly
so if you if you want to go buy guitar
don't just look up reviews
um and and look at you know the online
catalog kind of thing you there's really
no substitute for walking into a shop
picking up a guitar if you ask the
attendants
they should be fine with you doing that
and just give it a play
see how it feels see how it sounds and
see what kinds of guitar you like